welcome back to new rock stars marvel's
eternals final act leaves us with
endless questions and a
spoiler warning we are here to help with
no expectation of any sexual favors
unlike a certain watermelon sugar
sipping post credit scene cameo this is
inside marvel it's our weekly deep dive
into the biggest marvel news and this
week it is marvel's eternals now seen by
millions of people worldwide hey
like a big airship face in the sky
they're seeing this movie on big imac
screens that sometimes shrink the
widescreen halfway through a scene in
the back to imax again
the best way to watch a movie best way
to watch a movie i'm eric boss i'm here
with mt empty eternals is now officially
the latest entry in uh mcu cannon and
the world just got way bigger
way bigger oh my god dude like when the
movie started with like the opening
crawl i was like this is gonna be
special i loved i love getting more
cosmic stuff i love it
i love it in the beginning
perfect first words well um again
spoiler warning we've already started
spoil a little bit but just want to give
you another reminder we are going to
talk all about eternals dive deep into
that final scene of the eternals and all
the questions it provokes where did
aeroshim take cersei fastos and kingo
what new details have we learned about
celestials and how does arrows know
where to find them and how much time are
we gonna get with this guy before he
gets me tood uh not a lot not a lot of
time all right in the comics arrows is
very problematic but hopefully yeah it
actually it does happen that way uh well
before we get into all this there is a
brand new latest obsession shirt
inspired by eternals that you can get at
newrockstarsmerch.com it's called
immortal unity and it has this super
cool art deco design this is a limited
edition shirt so you gotta grab one
quick before it runs out we also have a
second eternals inspired designed at the
shop with a celestial design it looks
awesome as well you can only get these
shirts and other great original designs
inspired by loki shengchi the
mandalorian and other properties you
love at newrockstarsmerch.com
go there right now it's a great way to
support what we do here on the channel
um all right empty let's get into it
what's our first question coming out of
eternals well eric we gotta ask where
the heck did arisham take cersei and the
other eternals in the final scene of
eternals because they all got raptured
they all just got taken out by the lord
and just sweeped away somewhere where
they got
sucked into a black hole it looked like
uh well just want to give people quick
recap summary of how eternals uh
concluded right so the eternals assemble
in this movie to stop the emergence of
the sleeping celestial teammate hidden
inside earth ready to hatch
i don't know how you felt empty it's so
rare that we get a prediction right on
this channel so seeing that i was like i
had to pinch myself a little bit i'm
like i'm in the matrix i know it i know
it bro i have been tweeting about a
celestial being inside of earth in since
like 2017 2018. like i'm so excited i
was so vindicated
nerdstradamus got another one right
um so the way they try to respond is
fastos plans to build a device that can
connect them all in a uni mind for druid
to be able to mind control team it but
then icarus comes in and just says screw
your science fair project and
he reveals that he was the one who
killed ajax uh she actually wanted to
stop the emergence uh but instead he's
like no no i i have one mission and i'm
incapable of complex thought so i will
feed you to the deviants to keep the
other eternals busy distracted
very yeah yeah yeah he's stall stall um
and uh so that's why they were dealing
with the deviants the whole time is just
icarus one to keep them focused and busy
and yes i made fun of them for that but
like that's what i like about this movie
is they are having that real fair debate
of are we dooming the rest of the
universe by trying to stop the emergence
i thought that was kind of a cool
discussion to have but during the whole
debate on the dome sprite leaves with
icarus kingo sits out of the fight uh
which i gotta respect in a movie most of
the time people take sides i kind of
like to someone being like i agree with
you but i don't want to kill you so i'm
gonna hang out with karoon
we're gonna
he really just wanted to finish shooting
his movie
he's like we're almost done the crew
needs work like he was just looking
after the crew you know uh so after
icarus leaves this planet shatters they
come up with a backup plan you know one
of these moves in movies like why don't
you just plan to do that to begin with
of uh using cersei's fear as kind of a
backdoor hack entertainment and that
ends up working pretty well like during
this whole fight which uh this final
fight i loved watching the action i love
seeing fastest being like i want to do i
want to clip your wings
[Applause]
freaking athena doing the behind the
moves like oh my god slice
i uh
and then also i mean
the craziest moment sprite getting
clubbed to the back
by a rock it's so funny that these
hurdles are responsible for all these
technological achievements and they just
answer their head with a rock like a
cave it's like we're all done with that
speech right okay go finish the movie
please um so cersei reversed midas's
tiamat to turn him from gold into white
marble and uh hey forget wind turbines
on the coastline now the maldives got
quite an eyesore i heard tourism there
can we can we get a hotel room that
faces away from the giant dead celestial
baby please thanks
yo knowing zillow they're probably gonna
just put an apartment on each finger and
just like sell it for zillions of
dollars but you know some skateboarders
watch that and they're like yeah
fights all over that [ __ ] yo we gotta
drop off this finger bro you ready let's
do it
[Laughter]
uh so icarus responds as um many of us
do when we're proven wrong just flies
directly into the sun uh cersei makes
sprite a real girl and athena drink and
makari head off in search of other
eternals to set them free with the truth
and cersei can't go fast so stay behind
on earth until the final scene when
airship returns and snatches all three
of them up to tell them you have chosen
to sacrifice a celestial for the people
of this planet i will spare them but
your memories will determine if they are
worthy to live and i will return in
judgment and then thano and then
aeroshem opens a black hole and all of
them disappear leaving dane whitman and
all these other londoners ready for a
pint of gilgamesh's saliva beard so in
the post-credits scene arrows aka
starfox uh an eternal of titan brother
of thanos produces his own sphere and
says that their friends are in big
trouble and he knows where to find them
so let's talk about it where did
aeroshim take them well airshim said his
judgment of whether earth was worthy of
saving will be determined by the
eternal's memories which suggests to me
that their first stop might be that
world forge location that he showed
cersei in that whole exposition montage
this is where all the eternal memories
are stored now you could say if cersei
fastest and kangaroo are all still alive
here with their seven thousand year
memories intact would they need to go to
that world forge to have their memory
scanned i still think so just because
kingo had that whole line earlier of
like so they're stored in space like
that's something he is thinking about
directly and the world forge would
likely offer a transcript of past
eternal reboots from past dune planets
to compare their memories to so kind of
give it all in a bigger context
but also
i don't know if you thought about this
mt in captain marvel we saw the scrolls
have technology that they used to
extract memories
and we learned in this movie that
scrolls are actually derived from
deviants who got loose and evolved as
apex predators on that planet and
airstream is also intentionally keeping
a close eye on the deviants that
advanced tech might have come from
celestial influence and be a kind of
archive room or like a post-production
bay that airship just drops in on and be
like hey can you pull up this old clip
and editors are like fine
no that's a really good connection and i
did think about that when i was watching
the movie because like the there is
precedent in marvel's past with captain
marvel that memories are able to be
recalled and like there there could be
like a maybe like a certain like a
memory realm possibly like a memory
dimension where all of our mind stuff uh
go where like that's where you can
access it through the mind um but i
think that yeah captain marvel
definitely set up the the precedent for
um just memories being eternal and like
always being around even if you forget
them so it's i'm really interested to
see if like the skrulls had like a lot
more eternal technology on their home
planet of scrallows and you know was
able to adapt that into and make that
into you know um the memory
hopping device that they used in captain
marvel one question i had was why are
some didn't just himself judge the
eternals right there you know he's kind
of a mobile judge uh i thought well they
clearly defied his wishes they have they
aborted his baby right like that's they
did a lady it kind of looked like a
little airship too with the little six
eyes i was like oh my god his son is
dead
they killed him
you know one thing i really liked about
this movie was the way chloe xiao
depicted the scale and like they really
just used the six eyes of the celestials
those three rows and you don't even know
what you're looking at is it their eyes
are these six-eyed beads and just like
the first shots you see them you really
just see the the ribs of those eye holes
that go back through the helmet and just
by showing us one of those eyes cresting
through the earth we know what's coming
like it was just such a cool little
thing that was a simple six-eyed grid a
little you know six-sided matrix that
jack kirby drew and just by using those
simple shapes uh and making them huge
it's kind of like the the disc of the
death star you know just using a little
piece of it as like a synecdoche of the
larger thing that was a really smart
move um but yeah so airship is a god and
i would think the fact that he had to
sequester them to a second location
means that he must be bound by some
cosmic law in order to have to get a
second opinion to check the transcript
and i think i mean the way i read this
mt was that it's a sign of a legal
process in the mcu cosmic and yeah we
did get hints of a cosmic bureaucracy of
course in loki with the tva who governed
timelines and variances and we later
learned of course that that whole agency
was created by kang to give himself
really a multi-pronged well-delegated
legal bulwark in order to execute a
script but i think even the tva and kang
might have to adhere to a higher legal
authority and loki the show actually
gave us a hint of that in the emcee with
the living tribunal right the ultimate
chief justice of the multiverse we saw a
statue of the living tribunal in the
void in episode one of loki mobius
hinted there was some higher legal tear
than the tva
and we know that the infinity war
writers plan to have a living tribunal
trial sequence for thanos like in the
infinity gauntlet comics and now with
characters like arrows with pip the
troll with the other celestials with
adam warlock coming in we are now seeing
some of those cosmic elements from
infinite gauntlet coming into the mcu so
the theory i've talked about is and i
want to hear your thoughts on this mt i
know i've been talking for a while
i think eros connections are to these
higher authorities in the cosmos he
doesn't strike me as the kind of guy
who's going to lead a fight to free
cersei he's a lover not a fighter and i
think i i think he might get thena in a
position where she might be able to
fight cersei free you know maybe use
some of that mad weary to just go crazy
um but i ultimately think that arrows
could make a pretty good legal argument
that cersei like thanos in the comics
didn't technically violate any natural
laws she was just fighting for survival
for those that she loves and who better
to make that case than the god of love
so i think the next appear to these
characters whether it's in guardians of
the galaxy vol 3
that could be the kind of scene i could
imagine being in that movie but if this
is a storyline that will be picked up in
thor love and thunder i think violence
is more likely to be involved in how
cersei is freed because christian bale
is coming as gore the god butcher he
carries all black the necker sword or
some version of it and that blade uh in
millennia passed at least in the comics
was uh carried by the symbiote deity
null and was used to decapitate the
celestial nowhere that isn't been firmly
established in the mcu because null is
connected to the symbiotes but also
according to sony all of their things
are in the mcu who knows
um but we have talked about you
mentioned this on rogue theory mt that
gore's mission could be to kill all the
celestials and their descendants
including peter quill and that's why
peter quill is in uh 411 thunder uh that
slaughter could just like uh free the
vines of cersei so she can get out of
there um what do you think mt no those
are all really good ideas eric and i
think that you know but making the
connection up because eros's name like
you said is connected to the greek god
of love and i think that eros might make
a uh a good point of like hey like these
human beings are special like in the
whole universe because they have a lot
of love so like that's a really good
like i love lawyer i do like that but i
do have the love lawyer to sound so so
easy don't don't put that guy on
retainer
that's the new uh that's the next harry
style song the love lawyer
um but no i think that um aeros role
could actually be the prime eternal of
titan because he did have the sphere
like cersei had right and um you know
and all the titans are gone essentially
so like he's like all right i'm the last
one so i guess this one defaults to me
and so i think that they actually might
be so in the comics there is this um
city in like the incans built the city
called the city of the gods for the
celestials and um knowing that the mcu
likes to adapt things in their own way
we could be seeing them heading to the
celestial city of the gods that resides
outside of our universe because as we
saw in the opening crawl
we do know that the celestials came
before like they existed before the
start of the universe so the celestials
are technically
multi-dimensional beings like you know
like a dormammu or like you're
schumachorats or all them like they come
come from a different universe
essentially and so because of this their
home if they have a home it will
probably reside outside our universe as
well because it seems like they're
they've got multiple
fingers and multiple universe pies i'm
assuming anyway so i think that wherever
they're going it's going to be because
they went through that black hole it's
probably going to be somewhere outside
of our universe it's probably going to
be a tva-like
um scenario which would lead to a good
um living tribunal
court session and like um just another
thing that points to the existence of a
living tribune on the mcu um mordo
mentions the staff of the living
tribunal and that's right one so that's
another so like it they've been teasing
it for a while so it's definitely gonna
be coming soon there's a guy named the
living tribunal somewhere
and this is exactly the kind of like the
scale has gotten so high you have to
establish now what the hierarchy is
um
and the fact that like
we just it was implied that airship is
not the final judge you know he's kind
of like a circuit court judge he has to
appeal to someone whether that's a
transcript or something like he can't
just be judge jury and executioner in
that moment i just found that little
aspect interesting um and we do know
like the celestials each have jobs like
irishm is the judge and so he's probably
gonna be like listen i would uh you know
analyze you guys right now but uh that's
jamiah's job so uh he's gonna analyze
yet because jamaica mine analyzer nazar
the calculator uh boogity boo the trash
compactor
which is the most problematic one uh you
don't want to visit from one egg you
really don't uh unless you're arrows and
maybe you do
arrows will probably be into it you'd be
like yeah
let's go i won't say no to anything
uh
no has no meaning to arrows
oh no
oh no
i'm sure it's gonna be fine honestly i
gotta say casting harry styles as eros
is a genius movie literally because the
character is so problematic but like
just seeing harry styles in this we're
all kind of like oh okay
okay yeah yeah
people are going to buy that he's like
this like person that attracts so many
people because he's hairy styles and not
because he has powers he's just like
he's just a handsome man so like he's a
handsome man you need to cast a rock
star in this if you were doing uh the
marvel movies in the 60s or 70s you
would cast mick jagger as arrows you
know
you need who is our modern day mick
jagger and and harry styles fits the
bill like i i i really love this this
casted so much i love that he was
wearing he's legit wearing the star fox
outfit like
it really works and so bringing in
foreigners feels like the first time
it's like so much about this works um
it's like one of my favorite
post-credits scenes um but another
detail we had to talk about uh cersei
and makari suggested that they were only
able to form that final unimine because
tiamat helped them like it seemed like
they were grateful to team it which i
thought was a really interesting choice
in these final minutes like was timon
okay with being aborted like does he
actually in his
millennia of gestating inside earth does
he actually love earth and the humans
and feel an attachment to them and be
willing to just like give his life to
allow them to live
i think that that was the um insinuation
there i think that tm and like this
happens in the comic as well because
like tiamet eventually he meets up with
that jack kirby uh fulcrum figure that
we've talked about before and he's like
you i love these people like they
changed me and so like i care and like
his caring allowed him to ascend to the
fulcrum level it's like all right now
you are this like big even more cosmic
god so i think that
tiamet and like what's going to happen
when like these eternals go on trial is
that they're going to find out that you
know tiamet agreed to this he was like i
wanted to save these people because
these people have shown me through their
life essences i think like that's the
key here is that our the human life of
force is just so pure that tm was like i
can't i can't emerge out of my cocoon
this is just i love this egg i'm just
gonna stay here like you can kill me
it's fine so i think that yeah it's a
selfless act by tiamet which i i did
like that um yeah i like that too uh i
think it sounded like he was like
screaming in pain
turning him into marvel so it's kind of
like oh maybe that was like it screams
of i'm okay with this
it's okay
he was like yeah this is amazing
but it does leave us with at least an
implication that there may be other
celestials out there who do not 100
subscribe to arishim's way of doing
things like that she was just talking to
airship it's like when you start a new
job and there's just like the first guy
you talk to the cubicle across me he's
like i'll show you the way things work
around here
so the whole point of your cubicle is
you have to monitor the celestial seat
that i planted in there and one day it's
gonna hatch out of your computer and
you're just gonna have to deal with it
bro and then you talk to other people
around the office and they're like oh
don't listen that guy he's crazy
[Laughter]
do not hang out with that guy he's gonna
get fired he's gonna get fired
he's just like the yeah he's the ceo's
nephew but we're gonna fire him
but no i really like how you brought up
how the uh the celestials could be
potentially fighting amongst themselves
because like right that does bring up
the the potential for dissent and like
you know differing opinions and a
celestial like war potentially so i
think and we do see this in the comics
like the celestials at one point um i
think it was actually tiamat in the past
they were like yo tiamet we don't like
you so we're gonna gang up on you and
then shove you into the planet in the
comics and so yeah i think that
we could be seeing more just rogue
celestials like you know like an ego
even though egos seems to be different
from these celestials which we don't
really know how yet but like we see more
just differing celestials like all right
we don't like this plant so humans fight
each other which i would hope to see
yeah and i think that's the implication
that we should take away from eros in
this scene is that there are other
celestial authorities that he can appeal
to uh and that implies that there is
discord there is a disagreement there
might be even a civil war there are
other sides it's like trying to ask
permission for mom and dad
they're going through a divorce so you
really can't if dad says you can't go
hang out with your friends ask mom
she'll be like yeah sure i want you to
spend christmas with me so i'm the cool
parent now uh so i think that's that's
the idea is that the the celestials are
not all on the same page and i think
that's what's going to get exploited
ultimately to set cersei free but we're
going to discuss more what other uh
celestial personalities and other
eternals
are out there uh what might the
celestial's original plans been for
thanos and arrows we'll talk about that
but first we don't think some people
helped us make this episode when it
comes to meat quality matters and when
you invest in high quality meat from
butcher box the benefits go way beyond a
great tasting meal butcherbox sources
their meat from partners with the
highest standards for quality no more
searching the grocery store for 100
grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken wild-caught seafood and more i
just like a really nice piece of beef
and butcher box has really great
grass-fed steaks their sirloins have
that distinctive flavor they get from
the really best beef every month
butcherbox will ship a curated selection
of high quality meat right to your home
each box contains between 8 to 14 pounds
of meat depending on your box type
that's enough for 24 individual meals
you can customize your own box or go
with one of theirs either way you get
exactly what you want skip the lines for
your thanksgiving turkey it's hard to
get a good turkey not with butcher box
though this holiday butcher box is proud
to give new members a free turkey
isn't that great just go to
butcherbox.com marvel to sign up that's
butcherbox.com
marvel to receive a free turkey in your
first box we also want to thank get
upside for sponsoring this episode
there's an incredible app everyone who
buys gas needs to know about it's called
get upside our audience can make up to
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up all you got to do is
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code marvel and get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that's up to 50 cents cash back on your
first fill up don't pay full price at
the pump anymore get cash back using get
upside just download the app for free
and use promo code marvel to get up to
50 cents per gallon cashback on your
first tank some people who drive a lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash back and
there's really no catch the cash back
gets added right to your account you can
cash out any time to your bank account
paypal or an e-gift card for amazon and
other brands just download the free git
upside app and use promo code marvel to
get up to 50 cents per gallon cashback
on your first tank that's code marvel
all right empty back to eternals what do
you think makes the eternals on earth
who we learned are basically these
synthetic seed cultivators different
from other eternals like star fox and
thanos
are those eternals were were they
synthetically designed or could they
have been like the original eternals
that all these other carbon copies were
made from and and does that mean there
could have been like an original athena
in icarus and all them
i think that
the ending of eternals could explain
this because we see it's particularly
with sprite because sprite went from
being synthetic a synthetic eternal
being to a real girl it's like i'm for
real now um so i think that what
happened in the comics we learned that
you know um alars which is um thanos and
star fox father and suicide their mother
used the quantum bands to um make them
possible because in the comics eternals
can't have babies so i think that um
they're they use some of this energy
whatever cersei did to sprite i think
happened with thanos and star fox they
went from having these synthetic parents
to being
able to you know produce these real
thanos and star fox children so i think
that's what happened there but what do
you think what do you think happened
there um yeah i think that's a really
good explanation i think that uh
what we saw from the eternals on earth
is not the case for all eternals uh
universe wide i think there are other
eternals on other planets that were like
fleshy you know
that uh
that had longer lives and and were not
just like a super smart robot i think
that uh what we saw these turtles was
just the final stage of like a celestial
evolution and they're like uh let's just
make robot versions of them
and and i think that's what we saw we
saw this assembly line in the world
forge where it really is just the ten of
them on repeat on repeat on repeat um
and uh so i think when they're going
around uh planning to free all the
eternals i think they're in for a rude
awakening and they're gonna be like
there are no other robot eternals all
the other eternals are like oh we heard
about you guys you're the toys
you're the toy version of us
we are so sorry we're so sorry that the
celestials did this too
but we're having a great time we're
getting along with our humans
we're we're we're drinking uh gilgamesh
spit with
the prover you know the real thing it's
not fake spit it's the real thing it's
the good stuff
yeah
um
but i do love this twist that was one of
my favorite things about this movie is
revealing these eternals were just kind
of these programmed um carbon copies who
who just were helping destroy all these
different worlds i thought it was such a
dark cool twist in this movie uh and i
love that chloe gel witness direction um
what's what's really interesting about
this is that this could also explain
minerva in captain marvel like why she
looks like cersei because like she could
have literally just been a eternal robot
that they and she just didn't even know
like maybe she just had no idea that she
was eternal and she never had her memory
mt i know it's not rogue theory but you
get a rogie for that theory
thanks man
you fixing plot holes in the mcu
what a guy
um but yeah i think uh i think star
fox's goal is just basically to show all
of us how to love again like i i think
so far phase four has been uh just a
little slow to launch like there's been
stuff in shangchi that i love stephanie
turtles that i loved things in black
widow that i loved
my favorite stuff honestly has been on
the disney plus series and and i want uh
i want something in the movies just to
get us going and i think eros was that
like the arrows in the second
post-credits scene so let's talk about
that yes yes dane whitman
um he was about to tell cersei about his
complicated family history we hear the
voice of mahershala ali i know a lot of
people it sounded like jeffrey wright it
might have sounded like other people to
you it's been confirmed to be mahershala
ali blade which is super exciting
um so what do we think that complicated
family history was empty do you think do
you think he's about to say we're
vampire hunters or do you think that
there might be some vampiric origins or
is dane completely ignorant to any ties
with vampires right now
i think that you know the the vampire
ties are not gonna come until like blade
until cause like blade is probably the
nick fury of the supernatural world and
he's just like hey man uh don't touch
that uh because it's gonna block you up
yeah
no
no you're not ready for that it's like
no no no like i i i'm a black blade so i
know all about black blades okay
but no i uh in regards to dane whitman's
uncle nathan if i'm not mistaken um his
i believe his uncle was a villain he had
yeah he was he was black knight but he
was like doing dirty stuff you were in
bad stuff
he was the first black knight in the
comics and when he was introduced he was
introduced as a villain and then dane
whitman would take um over the role
later on and so we're probably going to
find out that you know this past life of
nathan garrett and maybe blade was
involved maybe blade had to fight nathan
garrett at one point and like they
became friends maybe later but like yeah
i think that that whole blade connection
is just to introduce this whole like
supernatural element in that and how
blade is sort of keeping everything
under control for the humans yeah i i
mean
the brief amount of time blade and um
dane whitman crossed paths it's on mi13
right during the secret invasion
storyline so when i saw that i was like
i maybe he could show back up in secret
invasion it is probably the disney plus
series i'm most excited for for 2022.
nothing against miss marvel she-hulk
moon knight i'm super stoked for all of
those but secret invasion is the one
where it's like i've been waiting for
years to see yeah they've been teasing
this for a while man like let's get it
so i don't know secret invasion is a lot
going on it seems like uh alien invasion
on earth would kind of have a different
aesthetic than supernatural folklore and
arthurian legend and that kind of thing
like when i heard that it was like
mahershala's voice here is kind of like
huh
like i would have preferred if this
sword was more tied to gore the god
butcher sword because that seems to be
the implication of the final moments of
airship's arrival dane's like what do i
do oh i go get a celestial slain sword
and
that's how i go rescue her but now that
this connected to blade it feels like oh
he's not going to be focused on saving
cersei any time soon we're going to
leave that to the eternals so their
whole relationship i guess
i guess they were sidelined for most of
the movie but it just feels like
now it just feels like dane whitman was
just kind of forced into eternals as
opposed to having like an actual
relationship with cersei that we're
trying to foster for the future
but i think you're on the money there
like i think that they are setting up
dane whitman to try to save cersei and i
think that blade's introduction is just
to get him used to the rules of the
ebony blade because if you just just try
to touch that you're going to be screwed
like that thing's going to take you over
you're going to go on a killing killing
spree um so we're sure sure is going to
be like all right
here's how you use it here's your your
family legacy um
and go off and go save cersei because
like we do know that the celestials
are probably gonna come back to the
earth and they're probably going to be a
problem whether it's these type of
celestials or maybe there's just uh the
evil celestials the dark celestials are
coming who knows but at some point we're
going to see the black knight facing off
against celestials i'm very very
confident about that because like you
said the ebony blade is specifically or
can cut through celestial armor like it
can kill celestials so that's going to
come in clutch later on and so it'd be
weird to introduce dane whitman in
eternals and then not have him serve an
eternal type celestial purpose
now do you think that uh that blade in
the box is the ebony blade or is like
that moment in the mi-13 uh storyline
like that was a fake ebony blade put in
there by dracula
uh and he was using that without
realizing it uh do we think
it was fake that's why there's that
latin phrase there that's you know it
could this be dracula's imposter sword
put in that box
that would be very interesting but
because it was a post-credits scene i
think that it will probably be like the
legit thing and it was like speaking to
dane it was like it's time to kill
killian all the time
so like yeah but but i mean a voice from
the shadows can be anything it could be
anything like
literally
perfect example yeah it could be uh
working against you it could be a voice
from your past or it could be someone
trying to corrupt you um i think it is
more interesting if that is actually the
ebony blade and the ebony blade itself
could just be cursed as opposed to it
being like i don't like it when it's
like oh but that was a fake like fake
infinity gauntlet i get that that was
just kind of they didn't know they were
gonna have a full marvel cinematic
universe when they made the first thor
movie um but like they've already done
that once i don't like the idea of just
like
what you saw was fake if you show us a
sword let it just be the sword we've
been waiting for you know oh yeah for
sure and like i think that you know
because of shang qi uh introducing this
idea of like magical objects being able
to whisper at you i think that the ebony
blade might actually be sort of like the
ten rings in the way and like sort of
just being this receptacle for
um an interdimensional being like what
if that voice
is an actual person outside of the
universe just being like whoo-hoo time
to enter like interfere with these
humans just like the dweller and
darkness did my cousin so i don't know
yeah do you think the whispers from the
sword could have been the same thing
that was summoning the 10 rings the
beacon or the
what the ten rings potential lemonade
who knows it could be anything outside
of our universe man i feel so yeah who
knows i mean we have nothing but guesses
but it seems like at this point marvel
has just like opened its index wide open
to anybody they want whether it's eros
adam warlock whatever so like
the options are endless schuma graph
coming and multiverse of madness we
think like there's so many different
people out there which just makes me ask
again why not mephisto
why not i feel like it's coming it's
gotta come he's coming
it's gotta be that doctor straight like
this is one big like origin story man
it's gotta be
foreign story um well we have a couple
more questions but do you identify as
crypto curious
if you've thought about entering the
world of cryptocurrency but felt a
little overwhelmed coinbase makes
learning to buy and sell simple coinbase
offers a trusted and easy to use
platform to buy sell and spend
cryptocurrency they support the most
popular digital currencies on the market
and make them accessible to everyone
they offer portfolio management
protection learning resources and a
mobile app so that you can trade
securely and monitor your crypto all in
one place millions of people in over 100
countries trust coinbase with their
digital assets whether you're looking to
diversify just getting started or
searching for a better way to access
your crypto markets start today with
coinbase for a limited time new users
can get ten dollars in free bitcoin when
you sign up today at coinbase.com marvel
this offer is for a limited time only so
be sure to sign up today that's
coinbase.com marvel
and thanks to helix for sponsoring this
episode we all sometimes lose sleep
binging a show but you shouldn't lose
any sleep because of a bad mattress
helix sleep has a quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect matches for you they have a they
have soft medium and firm mattresses
mattress is great for cooling you down
of sleep hot even a helix plus mattress
for plus size sleepers i have a helix
mattress i love it the quiz match me
with a medium firm mattress with lumbar
support that sleeps cool the mattress
ships right to your door for free no
need to go to a mattress store just go
to helixsleep.com inside marvel take
their two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life they have a 10 year warranty and
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't like it but you are
gonna love it helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com inside marvel all right mt i
want to ask you what do you think like
just the general public and other
superheroes of the mcu think about the
celestials now given that tiamat's big
stone baby corpse is in the indian ocean
and air shim just loomed over london and
freaked everyone out
bro you already know that this is one of
my top like my number one fear is to see
a big face in the sky it's my biggest
fear so me sitting in imax seeing that i
was like this is uncomfortable
it's the worst but no um like me i'm
pretty sure the people of the mcu are
even more freaked out honestly and i
honestly feel like this is probably
going to test a lot of people's
like faiths like seeing a huge god
appear in the sky saying that judgment
day is coming
that's gonna drive a lot of people crazy
and like um particularly probably mordo
who's probably like this is it this is
it this is strange's fault he did this
somehow this is dr strange's fault um so
i think that you know we're probably
going to see a shift in
you know how people
go about their lives because now that
they just feel smaller now like yeah so
the whole point of eternals was supposed
to do to you like the audience like us
as the audience to make the mcu seem
bigger but like i wonder how like you
know feeling smaller on the cosmic scale
is going to affect everybody yeah affect
their personalities right i love that
the mcu is doing this i i would argue
that
if you are a person living and working
in the mcu at this point you're so
desensitized you know
you've seen an alien invasion of new
york city the war
thor is the thing
you know like
so much has happened are they even gonna
care about secret invasion at this point
i just assumed half of us were alienated
right i mean this was london so like the
convergence happened to thor they're
just like
whatever yeah i've seen one cosmic event
you've seen them all when erisham showed
up right outside earth i was thinking
about the rick and morty joke of like
all the astronauts are dead right
any astronauts you
uh what i do love about it is it does
just kind of um
expand the battlefield it expands the
front the map of the mcu in really cool
ways and with things like sword you know
we've moved from the shield era to the
sword era
and i think it's gonna be interesting to
have movies that are just completely set
off world because at this point they're
gonna be like
um are parts of that celestial still
alive like can we dig and just check
that like
he just doesn't have frostbite on his
head in his hand because like
i don't want his foot to kick out of
australia right now and
like i think people will be like can we
just get off this planet like sprite had
that line of like human recolonization
could take years and i think half of
people on the earth would be like i'll
sign up for that wait list
is there a website like like i've seen
that wizard open up portals that go to
other places just right have us all go
two by two through that portal
yeah i would have been first at doctor
strange's door like hey yo uh i got my
bag let's go i know you're in there i
saw my snow plow guy this snow snowboard
from down the block is helping you guys
clear some snow out of that foyer
speaking of plowing and snow i hear a
contraction is pretty good this time of
year so let's go the track is great all
the minnesota people are going to be
like oh contraction sounds great
[Laughter]
just like home
yeah just it's it's warm it's warm here
they're out like they're like that a kid
wearing a shorts like short sleeve
shirts
like oh this is fine
cool the
the packers fans who are just wearing
tank tops in the middle of winter
that's wisconsin i know um all right so
uh final question mt now that we have
seen it we can talk openly with some
spoiler reviews we don't have to go to
uh length about this i've already opened
up my thoughts on this film i want to
hear from you now did eternals deliver
on the promises that you hoped it would
i think that this movie was a great
movie i really enjoyed it i thought that
you know the marvel lore and like we
said like the cosmic side of marvel
exploded with this one and we're gonna
it this opens up a lot of opportunities
so very excited for that and i think
chloe zhao did a fantastic job
especially given the coven 19
situations that all these people had to
deal with while filming so like all that
being said i think that there this movie
was great but i think that there were a
lot of missed opportunities in terms of
action in my opinion i think that yeah
you know the icarus stuff phenomenal
like
i could watch icarus fight in the air
for days but i just feel like you know
uh because we have all these powers like
i i left the theater wanting more makari
like fast-paced stuff i hope they give
makari her own series honestly like i
just love makari so much um so i want to
see more action from akari and like just
cool action sequences based on their
powers that i feel like we just didn't
get enough of so i'm waiting for the
eternal sequel or wherever next that
we're going to see eternals to really um
you know see what they can do but yeah i
do feel like this movie didn't
uh it could have done better um in terms
of action but i'm still very satisfied i
think marvel did a great job with this
and uh but yeah i think yeah this is
gonna be really fun i think in terms of
delivering on promises uh this movie
gave me so much in terms of celestial
lore to the mcu i love that i love that
they found a way to bring in arrows and
then uh deliver this interesting twist
with teema and with the eternals being
just kind of these puppets i i thought
that was really cool and i and i dig
that whole deeper theme of
uh one's purpose versus one's discovered
purpose of love you know uh and having
those two things be in conflict with
each other uh i love the elements of uh
the debate going down like a greek drama
of gods debating whether or not they
should intervene i thought that was
really cool but i do agree with umt in
terms of like the action that you would
expect from a normal marvel movie it it
doesn't quite deliver i i do think each
character gets at least one awesome
moment oh yeah so they did a good job
like makari gets some really really cool
moves it's just i agree with you it's
not like quicksilver days of future past
where people walked out of theater being
like oh my god that guy um but like yeah
gilgamesh i mean kingo kachoo like that
oh my god when he blew that
off
i was cracking up hey plus um but like
yeah i think uh i i think that's why
some critics why some audiences feel
like
you know i i think structurally you
might have had too many characters in
this i just don't know who you would cut
you know yeah i'm dying to know what
chloe john ryan ferpo's original pitch
was to marvel studios like what got
changed how did this movie come together
i don't know if we'll ever know um
but uh hopefully we'll find out someday
in the future but in terms of like the
promises we would hope to make i think
there was a missed opportunity to just
tease the existence of mutants but we
got to remember this movie was being
like conceived of and written and shot
in 2018 2019 early 2020 so like i
understand if that's like before marvel
really knew exactly what they wanted to
do uh the visuals i think were
incredible uh the sense of scale
especially in that final act is great um
yeah to me like
this movie won me over halfway through
with air shims whole speech to cersei i
think for a lot of people that's either
where it makes or breaks it uh i think
some people are kind of just leaning
back like uh and some of us lean forward
be like tell me more and i'm definitely
a tell me more a type um but uh yeah i
don't i don't like i i at one point did
a ranking of the mcu it's the video i
regret making more than any other video
for new rockstars any mephisto video i
hated that i did that ranking because it
was so stupid uh and my opinions of
marvel movies constantly change based
off of my life based off of things that
change and how i mature and how i see
the world so it's constantly shifting um
i would put eternal somewhere in the
middle you know it wouldn't be it's not
in the top tier but it's definitely not
the worst it's not i think it's
definitely worth watching and i think uh
like a movie like age of ultron right
also kind of a disputed movie not
everyone's favorite it did so much cool
world building to set up future plot
lines and future mysteries and future
reveals i think we're gonna look back at
eternals and be like
yeah without eternals we wouldn't have
this new cool thing though we wouldn't
have this new cool thing so uh i i look
forward to see how the mythology that
was now created from this movie
affects everything
me too and like i hope that it know in a
future eternals installment that they
probably move this over to disney plus
not because like i don't want to see
another eternals movie on the big screen
but because disney plus allows you to
have more room to tell a more
deeper story with and because they have
so much characters i feel like it would
just benefit from just having longer
time to tell the story like six hours or
eight hours i don't know it could be
better than yeah two hours because i
just love the turtles so much i just
want more honestly yeah maybe i mean
i'll say
pacing wise this movie felt too long but
i think they had to do that with so many
characters you have to kind of slow down
but i thought they were clever as the
movie went on when you flashed back to
things what you flashed back to is like
crazy to look at like you're seeing the
fall of the aztec capital you flash back
to uh to the atomic bomb going off like
i wasn't too bothered by the flashbacks
it was more like
now we have to see these two characters
sit
alone and talk about how they feel like
you want to feel like the movie's
ramping up at the end
there's a couple scenes in there it's
like we really have to have cersei
get all pissed off and then tina has to
talk her in to
uh joining the battle at the end it's
like no at that point i just want to see
that battle yeah
i get it um but anyway uh we want to
hear your thoughts down below about this
film i love that the whole world is
getting to see this now and make up
their own minds about how they feel
about eternals but that is it for this
episode of inside marvel next week we
will be back on wednesday to discuss
whatever your biggest marvel question
will be it could be about eternals or
maybe some other big news we might get
next week so be sure to send us all of
your questions about eternals and
everything else you're curious about
with marvel cinematic universe also
reminder next friday we're gonna have
marvel disney plus day it's not just
marvel disney plus day but for us
essentially it's marvel disney plus day
and star wars christmas for us um
we are excited hopefully we'll see a
trailer from miss marvel for moon night
for she-hulk for secret invasion uh or
at least release date announcements on
when all these things will come out in
2022 so we're so so excited um so don't
forget to check out our many great merch
options at new rockstarsmerch.com follow
me at ea boss follow mt mastertainment
follow new rockstars subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you so much for watching and we
will see you next week bye everyone
you